okay off we go
[Music]
Friday night I'm going nowhere all the
lights changing green to red
turning now of a TV station situations
running through my head
[Music]
look Maxie time you know it's clear that
I've been blind I've been a fool
to open up my heart to all that jealousy
that bitterness that ridicule
Saturday and running wild and all the
lights changing red the cream
moving through the crowd I'm pushing
chemicals rushing in my bloodstream
only wish to he know I've seen it so
clear I've been afraid
to show you how I really feel admit to
some of those bad mistakes I'm me and if
you want it come get it
crying out loud love that I was given he
was never in there go go
fair
[Music]
go ahead feeling
I'm Pamela
Bella
[Music]
BAM
yeah someday all the lights of London
shining sky is fading red the blue
[Music]
I'm kicking through the outer leaves and
wonder where it is you might be going to
then I'm turning back for home you know
I'm feeling so alone I can't believe
[Music]
climbing on the stair I turn around to
see you smiling there in front of me Wow
and if you want it come and get it
crying out loud the lovely that was
given heals
never a doubt go ahead feel it now
[Music]
go go
face
good go ahead fair
go go
fair
Bella
[Music]
Pamela
[Music]
Babylon
[Music]
Bella
never love while I'm away
[Music]